não me xinguei minha redes sociais você
tá enganado lembra
e aí ela que assistiu ao canal todo bom
vocês aí você gostou deste boné o
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo caso
você quer ra assim ele contar lhe dizer
é que qualquer coisa deixo aqui mas
estou pensando refletindo esse dia cara
eu estava no supermercado foi comprar um
uma cuscuzeiro agora o mercosul ea que
eu gosto e mail que gosta do povo é que
tem obrigado o rap ao e e ficar com medo
depois kuyt é é quando conclui né
só com os custo quando só tem custo os
coirmãos bancos por meio de guia os
coordenou está assistindo filmes em
madrugar cuscuz com recheio de concluir
os cursos com sala de cursos cuja ao
molho de cuzco 8 na sic era pequena
afirmou madeira de cuscuz é isso que o
povo pensa não é contudo mas eu como
busco isso que o rap público tem um raio
quando eu cheguei no lugar que tem 30
caixa está funcionando afirma que não
parecia o fim de implementar para a
merenda pensei quando chegar no final
dela mesmo não punha de macarrão com
salsicha e como se não bastasse a mulher
está no caixa também está tuta que não
tem ninguém trabalhando só então ela
fica em mim que está na fila querendo
salvar imã ainda que eu ficar com raiva
que não falar salgadinho faz a guardinha
é essa gac ea china demorando e menez
aguatins a guardinha fila andar um
pouquinho minhas aguatins aguatins água
mim
o lado hélio [ __ ] bruno que a fila andar
meu deus a guarde na minha cabeça
godinho começou das águas a guarda em
salgadinho à vontade e me disseram você
vai dar os aguarda um fax a criança
também tirou as esperanças de quem
ninguém está agüentando mais a marca lá
na frente da fila pela compra de 300
reais a feira e ameaça atingir 250 não
tem tirar o negócio vai à caixa com
maior preguiça do mundo cancelamento que
tem que avisar a outra pessoa porque
outra pessoa tem um cartão é o cartão
fica boa pessoa por não sei porque é a
pessoa vem de patins a pessoa está com
um cartão sem par na outra ponta o
supermercado e vende patins meu dividir
moto a rampa vou pular brasileira carla
no caixa a gente tem que esperar num
cartão de ficar com outra pessoa pra que
mexer e acha que já vocês que o céu
sempre deixa o cartão com você e não mas
é pra ter um controle de que você é
descontrolado e um menino agora de o
menino para perturbar a minha gente pelo
amor de deus certeza que ele vai crescer
e virar um pastor tudo o que lhe pedi a
deus vai daí pediu a geladeira de manhã
e de tarde chega a geladeira em casa
porque ninguém aguenta ficar perto do
banco
a mulher chegou pela hora da morte a
pessoa quando vem parece que vem assim o
seu cartão cancelou com e foi simbólica
é assim a mulher que faz o cancelamento
ela faz o cancelamento vai embora
martins começou empacotar negócio amanhã
eu prestar atenção e eu com a agonia
porque eu tenho uma aguinha gente que
não sabe qual sacola coloca as coisas
mesmo que para votar pela hora da morte
só puto com a vida dele ele pega o
responsável espanhol de lavá-los
faltando a sacola verde e pegou sabão em
pó e colocou na sacola branca burro que
todo mundo sabe que a culpa da caixa de
sabão em pó fura a sacola branca na
verdade essa é a função da sacola branca
rasgar e fazendo-se passar raiva verde
que a forte e resistir a tudo você pode
botar refrigerante pode botar sabão em
pó se pode botar tudo ela resiste o peso
de tudo existe ao tema tártaro engasgado
mas não acabar fio e um menino gritando
nem voz tinha criança mas lá tá com dó a
fazer gente vai fazer a vaquinha pra dar
um salgadinho essa criança eu queria ir
pra casa a minha cabeça só pensava meu
deus só queria tomar um café da manhã
comecei a imaginar aquela cena do café
da manhã e buscou bem quentinha a
margarina boa por cima eu gosto que eu
tive também quentinhas a informática com
o suíço a festa quentin que quando fica
dura marino technical ea marinha de
guerra tempo sinto que eu tinha na fila
saiu em gritante é mãe só uns água que
chegou minha vez o cruzeirinho e ganhou
cartão começou aquela conversa de quem
está trazendo pela primeira vez vai
votar como é que eu boto você bota o
placar em bola dentro eu posso ou você
vai comigo eu boto você queria pagar eu
voltei mais fácil ainda vou ter minhas e
eu digo uma coisa você e eu sou um cara
graças a deus tudo deu certo e até mesmo
o meu plano deverá bater mas eu mudei a
minha vida e hoje eu sou um cara que eu
tenho um padrão de vida que eu adoro que
eu amo como nunca quer perder não
importa quanto dinheiro você tem na sua
acontecer bota o cartão fica assim
aguardando resposta autorizando 70
pessoas trabalhando pressão meu amigo
negócio demorando autorização começa a
dar desculpa porque o sinal aqui de pé
no mercado é muito metal é muita então
nem é esse aqui é normal a galera
começou a
um parece que o cara do gol chutou bola
todos os ei curso conde vila assim até
domingo saudade morrinhos água e aí mãe
e bebê e agora também com diz assim a
gente é assim vai querer saber e mancha
parece que jesus passou a mão na cabeça
da gente falou que preocupa os filhos
mas estresse do dia a dia normal só
porque isso faz outros momentos
pareceres e mais feliz mais especial
porque eu cheguei em casa no outro dia
eu fiz um café da manhã muito o meu
concurso e margarinas impossível falar
em margarinas e jacira episódio da vida
mais claro que eu participei eu fui pra
casa quando conheceu casa aberta raquel
a marina foi muito legal então assisti
lá que é o primeiro link da inscrição
desse vídeo pode comentá lá porque
gostei de escrever você conhecer os
outros convidados que vão pra casa e que
gostei desse vídeo se você gostou e quem
não clicar em curtir esse vídeo que vai
aparecer um lindo lá gritando assim dá
uns àgua dinheiro então porque gostei se
inscreve no canal para não perder nenhum
vídeo tamo junto é na equipe b e c